[Music]
welcome to
ear biscuits the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time
hey i'm link and i'm rhett this week
at a table that is round but there's not
dim lighting
uh it's a different table at our
creative house we're going to be having
a conversation
that was spurred by a question that was
asked
during one of the ama sessions over on
the mythical society we do that i don't
know how often we do that
is it monthly uh is it every month
seems like it it seems like every month
it's gotta be my every month
um and kimberly society members ask us
anything
and then we answer them yeah for a whole
hour whole hour we're both sitting on
laptops answering questions
i i didn't i didn't answer this question
by the way and i didn't i don't know the
answer to your question
so i'm not going to give you the answer
i'll give you the question and i was
like
i was thinking about this question last
night and i was like this would be a
good thing
to hear link's answers and also to
analyze my what i'm going to call my
knee-jerk answers
so the question was if you could witness
any historical event what would it be
to go back and witness any historical
event and
again when you're doing an ama i mean my
philosophy is
i want to answer as many questions as
possible
you know i'm it's not like i'm it's not
that i'm not being thoughtful
but i'm not like you don't want to
overthink it because i really got to
think about this
because because it's live and you know
they're waiting for the answer to the
question and you want to get through it
right and uh that's why i didn't even
choose that one because i'm like dang
that's a
that's a big question well and a lot of
times i would avoid that question a
question like that
like this because of what my answers
were but oh
that's why i wanted to talk about it
just in the in the name of
vulnerability self-exploration
introspection
i thought it would be interesting to go
back and i'll go through my answers
which again
if i could i've actually thought a
little bit about them and i was like
i probably wouldn't answer this exactly
the same way but i want to explore what
my answers
say about me and then i want to hear
your answers of course you had a little
bit
we talked about it last night so you had
a little bit more time to think about it
um
yeah and i you know when you first
pitched this as a near biscuit i was i
said now let's not do that one because
like i was
not in a frame of mind to to figure it
out like
it's a very intimidating question i mean
and i don't know enough about history
like all of a sudden i feel exposed it's
like
shouldn't there should be an obvious
answer now
i'll talk about my process a little bit
about how i arrived at my answers
oh yeah and we also yeah to clarify
first of all you're not drinking beer
for those of you watching
uh not that there's anything wrong with
it but it's not apple juice either but
it's a kombucha
um we i gave three answers because i
couldn't narrow it down and i said my
three
answers in chronological order are and
so you've also given three answers
yeah even though that wasn't what
kimberly was asking she was just asking
for one couldn't air it down to
one so that's what we're going to talk
about today but before we talk about
that
what let's talk about the fact that uh
we're both wearing shorts
oh i see you looking at my and are you
looking at my legs or my shorts
well i'm looking at your shorts but it's
hard not to see your legs because your
shorts are incredibly
may i say unnecessarily
dare i say unnecessarily short now
okay i'ma stand up and uh for those of
you watching i'ma show you
my shorts go ahead and show them your
shorts you got some you look like a
freaking
i got uh golf shorts these are just like
plaid shorts
stylish man now what we don't as a
policy we don't wear we
we don't wear shorts to work or on video
but i i admittedly i've gone to an
extreme here
i mean i'm gonna stand on my tiptoes so
you can see that's
that's my that's my leg there that's a
lot of leg
that's a lot more like like a joggers
short
yeah these are these are swim trunks
because i've been working on my tan line
and i like my tan line to be very high
why don't i just do the podcast standing
like this
just be standing some people do it while
walking you stay seated and i'll stay
standing
but the reason why i'm wearing shorts is
not because
you know it's liable to be in the
mid-90s
but i i have got a break out of poison
ivy the temperature you mean not like
we're not going back in time to the mid
90s
yeah it's really hot yeah uh
dude i look at this thigh i don't look
at my
look at my my right thigh now i see my
tan line there
well i mean that's not i would i mean
that's not a breakout that's like you
gotta touch a poison oh do you think
you think that's that's you have a
crescent of poison ivy i have a crescent
of poison ivy i mean i've had i've been
covered with points that's four inches
well listen you think that's four inches
that that explains a lot how long
how long is that that is not four first
of all you're
going past it that's that's three well
actually
no it's three inches if you if well
you're going too far on that side
well i don't want to touch it okay well
it's three inches
it's about four you got three inches of
you have a three inch crescent of poison
ivy this is not
this is not a life-altering situation i
also have two dots right here on my hand
because it spreads via your bloodstream
and that's where i first noticed it i'm
like man my just below my
knuckle it's itching what is that is it
itching zit
i'm like oh no i remember this feeling
we used to get it in high school all the
time because we would
constantly be getting poison ivy because
we'll be gallivanting in the woods
and then right here on this on my that's
my right knuckle my left shoulder look
at that one dot right there and that dot
itches like mad
and then i realized you know what i've
been scratching my thigh under my
britches
i took my pants off two days ago bridges
and there's this
crescent four inch crescent three
2.8 inches so i've been i've been
applying
uh rubbing alcohol to it because that's
what the internet told me to do to help
dry it out
i mean you can take no calamine i know
that doesn't happen anymore
i'm just trying to dry it out and give
it some relief but
at a certain stage oh man i am reminded
of
when i had a whole lot like my whole leg
will be eat up with it
and my whole leg would turn into like a
one solid welt
welp what's the consonant at the end of
that word
welp well i think it's a welt it welt up
man
even this much had me up multiple times
last night
because i would wake up scratching it
well because you're only addressing
the dryness of it you're not addressing
you're not soothing it with anything
that's what countermine does you got to
soothe it well it can't just dry it
it cools it off when you're waking it
you're waking up scratching it it's
obviously something's not working
well then i got to go put more alcohol
on i can't let a 2.8 inch crescent of
poison ivy ruin your night
sleep i'd like i'd love for you to get
it you know i'ma take some whatever
oozes off of it
and under this table i'm a rub i'm gonna
rub it on you that's not how it spreads
can't get it like that
you get it from the oil on the plant the
oil on the plant's gone friend
now you just have you're having a
reaction i can't get a reaction from you
having a reaction so you're saying that
the
oil that comes out of the thing that's
not oil that's pus
pus yeah you're not like leaking fine
oil i'ma rub my puss all over you if you
won't shut up it would be very
unpleasant but i would not get a
crescent from
it just reminds me that i got after i go
in the woods i took lando in the woods
good gosh i'm so glad he didn't get it
did you wear
because he's freaking that short in the
woods no
but i sat down for a while and i think
that's when it happened
i don't know it could have entered my
bloodstream somewhere else and then
popped up there on my leg because i was
scratching my leg for another reason
i don't know much about poison ivy but i
don't
i think that i don't think you can get
it on your leg and have the bloodstream
take it to your hand
i think that it spreads within the
section through the bloodstream but not
like to another extremity
i i don't i mean any scientists any
poison ivy scientists figured out
hashtag
i'll be good by then i think you got it
on your hand because you touched it and
i think you got on your leg as you sat
down we got it so bad in high school i
had to go to a doctor and get a
cortisone shot no steroid shot
same thing oh yeah anyway yeah i'm
wearing shorts in order to air out my
[ __ ] legs
oh god i'm scared well why are you
wearing shorts
because we don't do that well i'm
wearing shorts because while we record
this podcast
here we don't run the ac and it gets hot
it's very hot i mean i'm gonna by the
end of this i'll be a shiny sweaty mess
because we can't run the ac i mean we
should just run the ac and let people
deal with the
the noise go turn it on i brought a
sweatshirt
because i knew you were gonna insist on
it it's crazy
after last time um but
it's interesting that even when we were
crazy we worked
it's being prepared when we worked in
lillington just the two of us in that
basement which did have a window unit
we wore jeans every single day like we
made
we wore flip-flops with our jeans and we
wore t-shirts but we had this like
idea that you can't get work done in
shorts well no
what we really decided was you know what
we're not gonna wear shorts
in videos i'm not gonna my legs aren't
gonna appear in videos it just
you look like a hack i mean if you're
i mean i'm sure mr beast could get away
with it i'm sure he wears shorts in his
videos i've never watched one
tell me you're calling mr beast to hack
no i'm just saying he can get away with
it because he has a different aesthetic
it's just like hey a dude with really
really good ideas
the best ideas the best ideas on the
internet maybe
in terms of performance i mean you can't
argue with the numbers am i a little
bitter
i've never watched his videos how could
i be bitter or jealous
but i mean i could see him wearing
shorts i think he does
i've watched him i mean i know he has a
big straw hat we try
too hard to wear to wear shorts because
that undermines the whole thing
but maybe that's it maybe that's what
we're discovering if we would just start
wearing shorts
wait why not wear shorts i mean shia
labeouf wore
shorts on hot ones yeah he did and he
didn't care
well i've been thinking seriously about
wearing shorts to the office because
this is not this is our problem to the
actual office
you know we're talking about i don't
want to set the wrong tone people are
liking good mythical more
some people say they're like good
mythical more more than like good
mythical morning
the show before it the actual show right
because
because and we're starting to figure out
oh they're picking up on something
right the shorts it's that we change
into shorts
mentally mentally we change into shorts
for good moving more it's like oh this
is just
it's just for anybody it's more
unbuttoned if you want to be here you
can be here but we're not going to
beg you to be here and we're not going
to care what you think about us if you
are here
we're in this together right i think i
think
i think that's the key to good mythical
more is that we put on our mental shorts
and you know what this is going to be a
good podcast because we've got physical
shorts on right but my thighs kind of
[ __ ]
itchy but your your particular shorts if
we're going to wear
shorts to the office or begin wearing
shorts more often i just
i don't think you can wear that kind of
short i'm a little bit
minor i'm a protein minor dress here
yeah i'm yeah
and longer and embarrassing that's a
seven that's a seven and a half
different ways by the way this is seven
and a half inches
i'm to my to my inseam
that's what seven and a half just looks
like
i mean are you going golfing later
actually i might later yeah
okay well then you're ready but but see
i'm ready to go swimming plaid shorts
look good on anyone at any time the only
reason i'm wearing these shorts
the shortest shorts i've got is because
the other shorts they don't they go
halfway on the crescent and they chafe
it
they chafe you crescent roll them up the
thing about plaid shorts is you can be
ready for anything you can be ready to
have a my tie on the pool side but you
can also have a business transaction
you could not do business in those
shorts
you could only run from business
or run to a business meeting and then
change it i don't like it i don't like
how we look
in shorts on on camera in a full body
i'm starting to like the way i look on
in shorts
well i'm not
okay these will be the shorts that i
wear if that's what if that's where
we're going
let's okay well then i'll put on three
pairs of pants
if that's what it takes okay we're going
to talk about these
these historical events that we would
like to witness but first we're going to
talk about
how you should groom yourself like a
chimpanzee
uh and you can do that with our help
because we've got pomade we've got beard
oil we've got lip balm
i mean your whole at least from the neck
up we can make you look like a million
bucks
i think we still have some cologne too
that may be going away so
if you want to collect that it may be
too late if there's some left it is the
last of it that's for sure
and i hate that because i really love
the scent
grooming products
smell like
us yeah stop but you know
style like yourself it you know express
yourself
on your head and on your lips okay
and only your thighs okay
so um you answered this question i mean
you you somehow came up with three
answers to if you could
travel back in time and witness any
event
in history now there's no exact timeline
but there's a couple of ground rules
here that were implied that at least
i assumed one is you can't change
history
you can't have any impact on it right no
that was implied i also
assumed that i'm probably gonna disagree
with this i can tell by the look in your
eye
that it couldn't kill you like if you
went like
i mean if somebody said well i'm gonna
go back to i want to see
a volcan a specific volcano erupting
like uh
uh there's one huge eruption that
a lot of people say they they wish they
could go back and see
but it'd probably kill you so i'm
assuming that i disagree with you would
be safe so okay
okay so your assumption was that you
wouldn't stay safe oh no no oh i thought
you were saying you could be killed yeah
i was when i give you my first answer
you'll understand that you're in a
hypothetical bottle of
ba what's the word bubble of safety
yeah so i assume that as well yeah and
in
in terms of how much time there's a
little flex here but this
really can't be more than like 24 hours
like i mean if it's a if you wanted to
go
if you wanted to go see a concert you
maybe you could do that but maybe
but you i don't know that you could go
to like a week-long festival the funny
thing about all my
all three of my answers is i probably
need about a minute
oh really yeah a minute right
because i was thinking okay that it
seems like we're thinking differently
well okay so okay because and this was
this is knee jerk but but these are the
assumptions you brought to it
but then you were like all i need is a
minute well because i because because
i'm going back
okay well okay let me just give me one
uh and i'm going in chronological order
and so the first one was the big bang
the moment
just before the big bang okay i was
right
so which again the moment before the big
bang the moment before the big bang
is i guess theoretically unwitnessable
because
there was nothing to but that's the
thing
was there nothing to witness and i'm
also i'm also
assuming that if there is some
god who instituted the big bang
i would be able to see this god do the
work right and so
so which again is first thing first
thing i'll be looking at is
is god wearing shorts did god just light
the fuse to the big bang
that would be my second thing right is
god in shorts
and is there some sort of lighter is it
one of those big light or
those are frustrating no no you know
it's like i assume
god has pushed one of the long lighters
like he's got the one that like i like
my girl with and right when you get one
of those things
you crank it up all the way or is this
just me
every time i get a new one of those
longy trigger lighter things
you know where it's got that knob it's
like the negative positive
slider go all the way yeah i hit that
thing all the way to positive
and i'm like wow it's like a torch i
think god has a butane lighter
and then after that like for cigars even
like because you could definitely smoke
cigars the next time i eat
well don't don't call god a he maybe
they maybe god god
i'll just say god maybe god lit the big
bang with a cigar they were
already smoking
[Laughter]
yeah that's nice when you start a fire
with
a thing that's in your mouth that you're
already smoking that's about as badass
as you can be
like in a movie when you've covered
somebody in gasoline and like lit a tr a
trail to them
right right god need not be badass he
has nothing to prove
he yeah you did it
yeah it's hard not to uh just tradition
uh okay but i thought then after a
couple of uses even though that thing's
on the plus you're like
the flame is so small yeah well let's
get back to the
the nature of the question and not god's
lighter um
that's fair so again now obviously you
want to know
you want to know how it started well
yeah i mean and
you'll you'll see all my questions uh
relate to these kinds of issues that was
where my mind was at at the time when i
answered this question it was it wasn't
like
what would be cool to witness and what
would be fun to witness it was
what would be like what would unravel
the deepest mysteries of the universe if
i had the ability to go do that right
knowledge so yeah and this one in
particular
this question in particular you know
when we shared our deconstruction
stories for those of you who don't know
a few months ago we did a series called
the lost years where we talked about our
history growing up
as in becoming adults working in
christian ministry
evangelical christians and now we're no
longer we no longer identify as that
i identify as what i call a hopeful
agnostic
um and it's interesting what people
lots of people on both sides were like
well
you really just can't be an agnostic you
know you're either an agnostic
theist or an agnostic atheist and i'm
like oh
okay that may be your opinion but i i
i'm not going to label myself what you
want me to label
myself uh because the thing that i am
agnostic about
is whether or not god exists so i'm not
going to be an agnostic theist or an
agnostic atheist because
that represents a disposition
in one direction or the other or to me
it represents like a
you know the agnostic atheist would be
like i definitively i'm saying that i
i i i'm not even gonna try to put words
in your mouth the people who who told me
that i needed to identify as one or the
other i'm just saying i don't
identify as i just identify as an
agnostic
but i have a like i said i'm a hopeful
agnostic right
so you don't know but you hope to know
and i'm not saying that i
hope that necessarily there is a god in
the traditional sense of
like the christian god you know
a personal god that has this
very specific interest in everybody's
life and is sitting in judgment or
sitting in love
or both or righteousness whatever your
description of god would be
but i just have this thing that i can't
let go of
which is it can't
it might it could be but there's a part
of my brain that's just like it just
can't be
just the universe right could it really
just be
the universe i mean i guess
theoretically practically scientifically
yes it could just be because you get
back to the argument where you're like
well god created it and you're like well
who created god so then god kind of
becomes your
de facto universe that has always
existed but that's where the big bang
raises this question because it's
basically saying there was a beginning
right
and there was potentially nothing before
it or
or maybe there was it exploded out of
another universe
or maybe it was another universe that
claps on itself and then exploded again
and i feel like if i could go back right
before it
it would be all of existence breathing
and it would be the beginning
the end of an of an in-breath in the
beginning of another out breath
but most of the the current data
suggests that
uh they thought for a long time that
maybe after millions billions
years of expansion that our universe
would then begin to class back on itself
but it's actually speeding up
and it seems like we're going to just
sort of
dissipate slowly everything will just
homogenize throughout the universe
so there's really no falling back
together and blowing up again
who knows i mean that's what things
that's what it seems like right now
i can make a new discovery to change
that yeah so if you go right before the
big bang
would you be seeing stuff i mean
it you wouldn't see anything even if
things were coming back together
i mean you said you said you you'd only
need a minute for this
like the moment before the big bang what
what i don't think you would learn
anything
no i would either see a bunch of [ __ ]
collapsing on itself right before it
comes down to that moment
or i would see nothing and now you can't
i mean literally
not if nothing exists i couldn't see
anything like where would
where would i be placed it doesn't exist
maybe this is this is i would just
destroy myself by
by trying to see this but again we're
we're we're you're in about
i'm going to be a safety bubble um or
maybe
if i was to enter into some sort of like
spiritual state in which it was oh
this is what you might call god existing
on their own
without any separate creation
and i'm assuming that in my hypothetical
bubble i would be able to witness that
as well
that's a risky one though i mean it
would
it would it could really
screw you up psychologically i don't
think the bubble could help with that
i don't think he could protect you and i
honestly i don't know what would change
in my life depending on the answer
because as i i mean i may have not said
this but
based on this answer i do not okay i
think i know where you're going with
another one because it's not that i
don't believe in god
i don't know and if it turns if i went
back and i saw oh no
the this is purposeful ultimately
purposeful
and there's an intelligent being behind
it it's not like i would backtrack on
everything and be like well i gotta go
be a christian again
because the reasons i'm not a christian
are not based on
a rejection of the calam cosmological
argument
you know what i'm saying okay it's like
right the reason i'm not a christian is
because i don't believe
um the tenets of christianity and the
historical basis of christianity is
reliable
and maybe we'll get we'll get back to
that one all right so
are we gonna yeah let's
we're going to pick up with this
conversation right here where we're
going to leave it off for a second
because
i mean like i said this is this is kind
of an intimidating question for me i
i couldn't rattle off three things off
top of my head i guess i mean it's
because i was also thinking what would
be a cool thing to witness
um and then i said and learned something
but also be fun to talk about honestly
that became another criteria
and the first thing that came to my mind
was um
how did they how did the egyptians
freaking build the
pyramids that's a good one i mean that
the huge freaking pyramid
i mean they haven't figured it out
aliens you got like
eighty-two ton granite blocks as locke
used to say when he was a kid
what a wollens a ones it was aolen's dad
80-ton granite stones they had to move
500 miles
and so then i'm trying to figure out
well if i'm gonna only be there for a
day
i could i could definitely witness how
they did it you know peop some people
say slave labor some people say
um that it's well it's it's skilled
labor there's hundreds of people there's
thousands of people
it it they estimate that it took uh
a couple of hundred years to build
the pyramids really yes a couple hundred
years
yeah okay then it probably wasn't aolens
right because they're probably just
people they don't have that that type of
patience
i think aliens would have done a lot
like that but look that up verify
how long how long did it take to build
the pyramids
because i you know you know how i am
with numbers but that's a good point
so i had to try to figure out okay if i
go back i could kind of solve this
mystery
you know i could say well this is how
they did i'm into systems
you know into production systems as an
industrial engineer by degree
so i thought that would be cool i
thought i could come back and
it'd be cool to say well when i was
there they were doing i couldn't
understand what they were saying
you know it's like i also assume that
the language barrier is intact
which that's a pro that that's that's a
problem 100 years
100 years edgar case reported that it
took 100 years to build the great
pyramid
most of the blocks were of limestone
quarried at giza or nearby
well still a long time but that's that's
not an alien timeline aliens would be
like
i think they're saying that weekend that
the limestone rocks were from nearby
but they were just the outer um
the outer part of the the pyramid that
now
the vast majority of that is going on
because you know because i was trying to
figure out because it was smooth at one
point
yeah do i want to see the pyramid like
on the day of its completion like
whatever
coronation or like all right where the
the ribbon cutting ceremony
yeah you know first of all i would just
like to see the
the pyramids in general but there's a
lot of smog
and i think um a smog is a problem smog
is a problem
and there's a lot of pollution there on
the because loch and i were thinking
about
egypt was one of the potential places on
our list you don't want to go when it's
exasperating the hot because i know how
you look in shorts
can you wear shorts over there certain
countries you just can't you shouldn't
be wearing
sports i believe you can as a as like a
dumb tourist
but it seems but but but they put um uh
limestone smooth limestone pieces that
they cut and made the whole outside of
it smooth and white
and this thing i would have loved to
have seen it in during the ribbon
cutting because it
it would have been a shimmering five
450 foot tall it would have been awesome
but it's not in the middle of the desert
but it's
but and i can still find out probably
how they did it no you can't no during
the coordination unless the aliens are
still there and they like cut the ribbon
and get in their saucer and go
i think i would go for one day while
they were building it like at the
like at the two-thirds point where
there's still hall
at some point where they're still
hauling big rocks because i can't talk
to them
i can talk to them but they wouldn't
understand me right but
but i i think that's what i would do i i
kind of i like
where you're headed with this kind of an
obvious answer but but i feel like
most likely like i'd say
99.7
chance that if you went back in the
middle of the building process it would
just be like oh
okay this engineering technique
that's impressive pulleys
levers log roads whatever it would you
know it would be some of the theories
that exist already
but there's a new theory these are gonna
be like they turned the desert into like
mud roads yeah it's because i mean it's
something
i would be ultimately practical but it'd
be pretty cool because you could come
back and you could be on
like one of those shows on sci-fi and
you could be like listen i mean i know
this guy with the
big hair thinks that aliens did it but
yeah
i the man in the short shorts i took a
bubble
back to the time and i can tell you
definitively
people really wouldn't believe you
though i mean when i
when i looked at like the ancient
temples in thailand when i
when i toured them and walked around
them and walked right up to a lot of
them
i mean they're like you know they're not
near
nearly as tall as the as the great
pyramid or anything
but it was really cool to like to
that's the first time i've ever been
around ruins you know which i've talked
about on
on this podcast before but it was cool
to just
imagine what it was like in its in its
heyday yeah
ribbon cutting but you could kind of go
to other temples
around thailand and and then see that
too
so i didn't really feel like i needed to
travel back in time
really this is what it looks like this
is what it probably looked like yeah but
that that would be cool okay
uh we got since we got four more to
cover between the two yeah what's your
my next one was the moment of a
abiogenesis so the moment
that the first life form
came to be right that has to look boring
like what are you so you're talking
about i'm not listen again like i'm
telling you my knees your
responsibilities now that microsoft i've
thought about it
more it's like yeah i couldn't because
i wouldn't know what was going on well
probably something with like some amino
acids coming together to form a more
complex structure
yeah yes i'm not really visible to the
naked eye but
here's the thing what about just change
it to dinosaurs just say i'm not
changing it because you got to you got
to roll with me here and understand what
i'm going for
okay because again i would have one
minute all i need is a minute
to to tell you whether one of two one of
two or three things is happening right
so if you go back to this moment um
you know many people would say well that
moment doesn't exist right there was
never a moment
in which life sprung from inorganic
materials right
because god did it right according to
the bible or whatever your
your religious text of choice would be
right so that
there's not a moment or if it was a
moment
it's something that you would be able to
ascertain whether or not it was
supernatural
but so if you just asked to go back if
you rubbed the lamp and it was like okay
i'm gonna send you back to the moment of
what did you call it a genesis be like
all of a sudden
there would be like adam would show up
he'd be like hey man
right but so i i think there's a very
very small chance that that's
anything like that happened right so i'm
that's not why i'm going back
and i actually think that if there is a
god who has a purpose for the universe
it would be very difficult to ascertain
the purpose
in any other moment in the history of
the world other than right before the
big bang
right like that to me that's a more
definitive point because
j even if life sprung from inorganic
material at some point in the distant
past
and then it slowly has evolved into what
we have today
that's an amazing thing and that may
require a god
but it isn't like you it's the kind of
thing you look at and you sort there's a
qualitative conclusion that you come to
which is
i believe that there has to be a god for
this process
it isn't like i saw a big finger come in
and touch the water
you know what i'm saying it's not i
don't in other words i don't think you
would ascertain like a supernatural
moment so that's not really what i'm
going for
but it's whether or not
it did happen that way or if it was
awelens and i'm serious about this one
because okay because i think that
there's a it's a legitimate
first of all can i can i just say as a
tangent that
i mean we know that there's when i
talked about
adam and eve of it all we know there's
christians who think that if you went
back in time you would go back to a
a microscopic amino acid
level you know point in
in the evolutionary process that then
there are many that believe that like
the per the first human the per that
that was part of it and they would go
back there too
there's still an atom that could be like
maybe there was some divine
uh injection of a of a consciousness a
soul no that was my point
my point was if i went back to that
moment that again like you said many
christians believe
yeah in the in the in the scientific
timeline of how things happen yeah they
just think that god is responsible for
it
right and even if you're able to figure
out how to
synthesize amino acids into some more
complex life form in a lab
all you're doing is proving that it
takes some sort of intelligent
input in order to happen right and
that's what god was responsible for
i get that so back to what you're saying
you went back to see
if there was an alien deposit
made on this planet right because
there's some really interesting things
like
you got the cambrian explosion right
where all of a sudden in the fossil
record there's all these
complex organisms that seem to kind of
come out of nowhere on a geological
scale
and so i i my best guess is there's
still a natural explanation for all this
stuff
but yeah i mean you should look at the
cambrian explosion on my right thigh
but what if the very first thing that
happened
was like us alien coming in with a
little like
a little like little thing and it's like
like oh here let's serene
let's syringe this why are you motioning
a syringe from the nipple
all aliens extract life juice from their
nipples
it makes that noise i sadly i don't
think you'd see anything
because well probably not i think that
would be able to come alien who's that
advanced
even if the alien do it
it would be some sort of you wouldn't
you probably wouldn't see anything
they're not gonna waste their time and
energy to physically
show up and doing doink no but i'm
saying that i in my hypothetical bubble
i would be able to be present even if
they sh i'm not saying they showed up
and squeezed it out of their their
literal nipple
but maybe they had like some sort of
cosmic
you know quantum powered needle that
flew through the universe and then
tracked itself onto habitable planets
and
planted the seeds of life what if that
what if that's what happened
what if that ends up being the
explanation for why there's life on
earth
and elsewhere potentially because some
other species i just think they would be
so advanced that you wouldn't be able to
witness anything meaningful
to you but anything out of the ordinary
yeah anything mechanical
like i'm just i'm i'm just i'm saying i
think i would be able to
see something i think i'm influenced by
the
the three body problem but they start
talking about how like how
different beings operate on so many
different dimensions
like fourth fifth tenth dimension that
we can't even
well interact we haven't talked we
haven't talked about this we should we
we're gonna do we're gonna not only do a
podcast about it but
we've talked about how we're actually
going to try to do it but yeah there are
people there's a there's
like a large movement out there and
because the theory is that aliens are
operating on a different plane of
existence
what we might call a spiritual plane you
can actually in sort of like a coast
what was the name the coast-to-coast
what was that radio show yeah who was
the
who was the host of coast to coast um
jim
bohannon maybe i don't know what a great
show
um but there's a lot of people and not
just people that you would just
traditionally i
uh call a quack but people that seem to
be
now that you think you might be one
rather quiet
no but i but i i like to allow myself to
believe the possibility and we actually
have some
pretty good friends that we trust who
have had experiences that are difficult
to explain
i prefer the phrase entertain the
possibility because i think that is part
of my motive
oh yeah even if it's not true it's it's
it's
fun to engage in and until it gets scary
right so anyway that is something for
the future that we that we may be we may
be legitimately trying to make contact
with aliens
okay so so my second one i i have to
believe this is your third one oh
okay uh i mean the whole jesus of it all
right you're going back in time you know
i mean you
if you grew up in a way different than
us you might say um
buddha right but
but but probably not and i'll explain
why when i get the money i had to say
i'd say jesus because i have you know i
have so many questions that i
you know i hung my life on and then like
now i've taken my
i've taken my my coat rack off of the
off of the jesus rod oh my god
and uh gosh i didn't mean that i thought
about that analogy a little bit more
uh what's it called the thing that you
hang your clothes on a curtain rod
i mean rod is the correct word it's not
a curtain rod it's a closet
ride right yeah and now i'm like you
know i'm
my clothes are just all floating so i'm
trying to figure out okay
is that am i going to go back to the
well again i'm thinking it's got to be
less than 24 hours so i can't go back to
like the execution of jesus and then
wait for three days and hang out at the
right spot
to see if he come you know if he raises
from the dead
i don't know why you're getting hung up
on the timeline because yes this is this
is my third thing and i just said the
resurrection or non-resurrection oh
jesus
so the resurrection i'm assuming that
the person in charge of granting this
wish
who ironically is probably god could
plop you down on the right
puts us in the right spot in the tomb
inside inside of the tomb maybe outside
of the tomb
you probably don't want to be in it i
think i ended up landing on
you know when you start when jesus
started appearing to people
when jesus appeared to but you wouldn't
know what he looked like jesus appeared
to the disciples in the
in the upper room yeah i wouldn't know
what he looked like but
and even in the even in the bible it
talks about the first time that they saw
him they didn't even recognize him
yeah that's interesting which is always
interesting to me um so i well i thought
about that so you're shooting that down
and then i'm like why not the moment
okay then what about just um a miracle
like witnessing that's what i'm talking
about the the
well not the resurrection because i i
think that's hard to witness you mean
like feeding the five thousand yeah feed
it like
he's breaking walking on water he's
breaking up some loaves and fishes
water to wine water the wine restoring
bringing somebody back from the dead
storing their eyesight yeah i think it's
got to be uh
i think it's got to be raising lazarus
from the dead it's got to be that one
i think that the fetus that was pretty i
think defeating the 5 000
is one that you could not like lazarus
could have been
it could have been like uh this guy
hasn't been dead for as long as they
realize or
they thought maybe he was just really
sick you know what i'm saying
what there's there's other ways to
squirrel out of that one but the feeding
the 5 000
is like all right we got you don't have
to know that you've got a couple of
things you don't have to know the
medical condition
of like someone was he really blind
before the
for jesus made the mud pie in his eye
yeah yeah
i was thinking about that one too
because like i saw this kid bring
this bread and this these fish
and i i was right there and then it just
just kept just kept coming and and
the reason i'm choosing the resurrection
because first of all
i think what would i mean my best guess
again i'm in the upper 90 percent on
this
not to be dismissive event many millions
of people
billions of people believe that these
things happen i don't
um so my best guess is that that story
the feeding of the 5000 you would go
back in either a
it never happened at all like
it's completely made up or b it's based
on like
this one time that you know
they made a lot of food go really far
and it was pretty impressive and it got
turned into the story that it is
whatever right
but the resurrection but but if you went
back to that time
and then it was a flop or not nothing
happened
be like okay well it didn't happen
that's okay so that's what i wanted to
get it get at because i
again this has not enough to rule out
every other thing but it would well
that's why i go back to the resurrection
because it is the crux of it all right
it is
it's just it's just hard to know like
all right it's not hard to know if
you're in the tomb
yes and he's and he's dead and then all
of a sudden he sits up and
it's not like he comes out like all beat
up the dude comes out with a new body i
mean this
and there's an angel there yeah this is
this is definitive stuff
okay yeah uh and also it it is the crux
of it all just like paul said
you know if christ didn't rise from the
dead then this is all in vain
like we should be pitied above all
people um
okay i'll go with that then and so
that's a pretty big deal but the
for me the this should have been our
first answer
well i was going chronologically
chronological but i was also kind of
going to like the biggest question
which is is there purpose behind
all this and like i said i tend to
believe that
i tend to want to believe that there is
and then there's a second question is
like
is there some point of intervention in
the in the in the
origin of life and then this
is really zeroing in on something that
is just very personal to us right the
philosophy that we
hung our clothes on whatever your
analogy was
for the majority of our lives and based
a lot of our
early life decisions on is based is
predicated on the idea
that this actually happened right that
jesus did raise from the dead and then
kind of everything flows from that and
then you're
able to take other things like feeding
the 5000 and be like well if he rose
from the dead
sure he could do this right um
but i was i was
interested in the fact that that was one
of my answers right
because i think again it was a knee-jerk
response
but i'm like why do you want to go back
to
that moment because you don't know no
but see i feel like i
i know i don't know but i feel like
again
what are the i i'm if you saw him
raising the dead you'd be blown away
he'd be like
that would be a surprise that's not what
you're expecting to see not even close
to what i'm expecting to see what i'm
expecting to see is either
i i don't i i believe that
the information we have about the post
the life of jesus and especially like
the post-death
events is like i think it's legend right
i
you know i i think that they're i'm not
i'm not one of these people that is
saying that well
this is my i subscribe to one of these
like the swoon theory or one of these
other ideas that he wasn't really dead
and then he fooled people into coming
back i would just be like
he just was a dude that was a
revolutionary that everybody loved and
he got killed
and then because people wanted to keep
his
memory alive they you know it's there's
some
humans can freaking invent all kinds of
stuff
right i mean look at what's happening in
our country right now there's a bunch of
people who won't wear a damn
mask it's like there's all and they'll
die over this
so it's like it they're you know it
doesn't mean
too much what you're saying is people
die for all types of beliefs
right uh and and also the whole idea
that the disciples died for a lie
is and that's proof that's super suspect
and we actually don't know that's the
case
because we don't actually know
definitively historically the
circumstances of their death so
anyway but i would really like to know
though it'd be better than talking about
it like we are right now
right but hey i was there but i think
for me it would be it was like
the thing is there were people who say
they were there and then
you know it's right right but i guess
what i'm saying is that it's not
definitive for me it's frustrating for
me
it would be this just like okay and i'm
not saying that i
i legitimately i do not sit up at night
i don't think about this on a regular
basis
but it was when that question was asked
it was like oh let's you know let's
scratch that off the list because
not just for me personally but and again
it's not like i could come back and say
hey guys it didn't happen i went into
the bubble and it didn't happen
now all these people would be like well
we're not christians anymore that it
doesn't work that way
yeah but it was this thing that's like
okay that must still mean
more to me than i even realized right
the the need to want to confirm the
decision
that i've made to come to the conclusion
that it didn't happen
that i that yeah definitely and i think
a part of this is also
i don't know if you did you end up
reading the universal christ by richard
rohr
uh no so richard rohr yeah at least
um who's a franciscan monk
who's written a bunch of incredible
books
um from a very different perspective on
christianity than the one that we
kind of came up with um and it's
definitely a much more palatable
form of christianity for me personally
but i really like the way he thinks
about
the idea of what jesus is and what jesus
jesus represents and what
what the christian life is all about i
mean so much so
that i'm like oh i could i could get it
i could get into that
like that's when i read it read his
works that's that's how i think because
it's just like
it's a it's a way to kind of capture the
hope
that i have and also apply it to the
tradition that i still know
relatively well but not in a dogmatic
way
where it's just like he basically take
so christianity for me most of my life
was a set of
you know principles basically a set of
statements that you had to agree with
right and he's like
this isn't we're not gonna that's not
what it is it's basically a way of being
and which is an attractive thing
but he talks he believes in the
resurrection
he actually talks about it in the
universal christ and talks about
the moment of resurrection he
anticipates it being like you would see
like light
like pouring out of the tomb like
i'm not gonna i'm didn't haven't read it
recently so i'm not getting this right
but the idea that it was like a dude
walking out
and talking to people and i'm not sure
exactly what he believes but he's
basically saying that this is like a
cosmic
event that represents something much
bigger than traditionally we've kind of
given it credit for
so i think that it was kind of on my
mind a little bit it's like okay well if
i go back and i
see what i'm expecting which is
you know some natural explanation
body stolen it wasn't even as
eventful maybe his body was consumed by
animals which is often happen to people
who were crucified
lots of different explanations
uh but if i went back and i saw
the light or i saw him emerge or even
just an angel
it's like hey you just missed it like
everybody else by the way
yeah you know it's i i know i'm sure it
can be seen
as a beautiful thing but to me
it's a frustrating thing it's like
something so momentous
like no one saw it no one saw it i mean
and then they yeah people jesus appeared
to
you know people afterward according to
paul up to 500.
but one time but it was a small movement
man
and it wasn't you know it was like it's
just it's frustrating
well it's frustrating i again i think
knowing what
i don't know knowing what we know about
the way people
work and the way people begin to believe
things
and the people's disposition to believe
things
it is not unbelievably unbelievable to
me at all
that there could have been absolutely
nothing that happened
that and still the movement would have
started i know people say that like you
can't explain the beginning of
christianity without the resurrection i
just disagree with that
um but i think that if i
saw it because look at the other
movements that started right there's all
kinds of look at all types of movements
right big and small and uh
but i think that the the idea
because i think the question is if i
were to see something if i were to see
something that it was not what i was
expecting but it was
the resurrection in some form like what
would that do to me
right um would i have all of a sudden be
like okay i take back everything i said
i take back all the issues that i have
with
the historical claims i take back all
the issues that i have about the
you know the scientific stuff
archaeological stuff
no i don't think that i would but i
would be like oh
okay there is something here
uh that's very significant and might be
the reason that we're all here
and it's got something to do with jesus
um
and again there are plenty i mean i
think richard rohr is an example of it
there are plenty of christians who
don't get hung up on those things that i
would have
had an issue with and were the reasons
that i left
who kind of hold to this
the core tenet that jesus represents
this you know restoration of
of of god
rest you know reconciliation of god and
people that broken relationship
being healed but i kind of there's a
part of me that is i'm
i don't dispute that anyway do you know
what i'm saying like
i'm that's cool i'm okay with that i may
not be
personally practicing it or experiencing
it
but i don't have a i don't have a
problem with that idea i don't have a
problem with any of the stuff that
richard rohr said in his book in other
words
uh i would like to think that i am open
in the same way that if i went back
if i could do this exercise that i would
be open
to whatever on the other side of that
time warp that i would witness
i would try to be as open as possible
but try to be as
open as possible now well i mean you
know our best friend
mike mccarg wrote a book about
this in a lot of ways right so he was an
evangelical christian he became an
atheist because of
kind of studying like reading a lot
and then it's called finding god in the
waves if you're interested
and then he had this supernatural
experience
with jesus yeah and
so he he would still call himself a
christian but does he
hold to the evangelical tenets of the
faith not even
not even close but he but he holds to
the idea that
there's a loving god with a purpose well
jesus
jesus doesn't make you an evangelical
and yeah and jesus is a
is a central part of that for for him so
and again he's way smarter than i am
and he's a close friend and i'm not
going to dispute his experience
but for me but it was a mystical
encounter and if i had enough and so i
feel like if i had a
mr and i am i continue to be open to
that kind of encounter
i mean i just secondly i was talking
about potentially connecting with aliens
so i'm open to quite a bit
uh but the i think it would just
it would give me a little bit of
motivation
to move in a particular direction from a
spiritual standpoint
that's that's what it would do i've got
one more
because i mean we could talk about this
all day right
um but to complete my exercise i was
like man i got to swing the pendulum a
little bit
i mean i wha what would just be fun like
i'd love to have one that was just like
i mean what would i enjoy the most going
back to
and i was like it probably has something
to do with music that would be cool to
like witness
the first music is the first the first
caveman to go like dog
no what is happening i think i'm singing
do you think the first song came before
the first word
was it like oh
yeah that was it what is smoke on the
water how does it start oh
you think smoke on the water was made by
a caveman who couldn't speak
i believe it sounds it's the most
caveman-like
oh riff i don't think that's not my
answer this is what i'm going it's not
i quickly moved on from any of those
thoughts into
well i was like i mean it would be cool
to go to woodstock or like
the last waltz the band's last concert
i mean but then i'm like you know i'm
not much of a concert guy well i mean
the beatles last performance on like the
rooftop of the
uh the apple building
um man that that would have been cool
but i'm not that big of a beatles fan
and
um i was like well i'll probably just
have to go with the merle haggard thing
so okay and then i can i guess what what
you what you went with
yes because you're going to be wrong
well i thought you were going to say
when johnny cash performed
um in san quentin and merle hacker was
in the crowd oh that would be a good one
but that would
so then i would be in i'd be a pr
i'd be like oh that would be cool i
didn't even think of that that's a good
one you'd be
you'd be a bubble above merle and i'd be
f i'd be i'd have to find merle in there
that would be really cool um
i actually settled on the recording
session for my favorite merle song um
i'm always on a mountain when i fall is
my favorite mural song
which incidentally he did not write so
that kind of makes me want to change my
mind
um you know the album from 1978
um i'm always on mount wanna fall also
the the title track which is my favorite
and then
uh it's been a great afternoon is the
second track which
is maybe my second roll song talking
talking about having a hangover and then
having having an
afternoon delight to get over it's like
okay
you can write this stuff and it'd be on
country radio in 1978
yeah so i would travel back to the year
i was born
and instead of going to the concert i
would go to i would love to be
hanging out in the recording session
because
i love those songs because those two
songs in particular
they represent my favorite moral songs
because of the production
and the decisions that are made and you
know the musicianship
musicianship and
i mean someone like britain
i interact with him with music a lot and
it's you know he's
he's so into live music and he's
connected with that but like
that's something that we never really
did that much you know it's like
and i feel like i'm we missed out on
that but with the
way that he talks about it but there is
something magical about being attached
to a song
a particular performance of a song that
was
laid down and it was let's say it was
the most like they
he wanted it to be so it's like every
pluck of the string
or every you know every every hit of the
hand on the lap
you know how on uh it's been a great
afternoon the drumbeat is just a guy
playing his lap with his hands
it's just so creative and
you know you feel like you're in the
room and i would love to be in the room
and say
and see that happening so every because
every time you listen to the song it's
like
i was there the one time that they laid
down
this track forever you know i was in a
bubble i was in a bubble
i was in a safe bowl and they didn't
know i was there no i would want to i
would want to talk to him
just hanging out i think i think in my
old age i just want to hang out in
recording studios maybe i'll be like a
recording studio
janitor slash soundcloud studios are
going away though man people are just
doing in their bedrooms
just a person in someone's bedroom which
is weird so i would go back to 1978.
merle's first album with when he left
capital he went to mca
he was like he was kind of faltering a
little bit he wanted to try something
new
he brought his band over and like he had
this jazzy stuff he had this yeah he had
this renaissance
the album after that was serving 190
proof you know
that's one of his best albums that might
be my favorite album
but this was the moment where it was
like maybe in the studio
you could sense that there was a turning
point because it was
and i would know that so it's like oh
this is exciting and it seems just like
an
i don't know how it would seem you know
maybe it would suck
i'm sure it would be awesome but it
would probably also be
somewhat underwhelming right that
opening acoustic like
[Music]
you know at the beginning of the way
that this wait just like watching that
happen
to tape yeah i mean they probably
got like oh it was the seventh take it
was the seventh take they used
you know what i'm saying yeah but i
would be there for that take no but that
would be cool
when you hear it six times that'd be
better than from your in the heat of the
egyptian desert saying oh yeah no the
bubble is air-conditioned oh it is
yes you could be naked in the bubble and
no one can see you can't get hurt
you don't i mean if now i want to talk
to people as like a
a wandering stranger well that's a
different thing being able to i mean if
jesus rose to the dead i would want to
have a conversation with him
well yeah you can talk from it they can
hear you it would kind of be
disconcerting for
merle probably there's a naked man in a
bubble i mean
but they change the if they change the
trajectory if you can have a
conversation then that's a violation of
the rules because at that point you can
change it because
when i thought more about this i did
think
you know practically speaking i would go
back to like
whatever however coronavirus started
right
most likely somebody ate something right
that's the big that's the best theory at
this point i thought we were gonna go
the whole episode without talking about
everyone about it we already talked
about masks maybe
maybe it was it wasn't it was engineered
by somebody okay
maybe that happened but like go back to
the moment where it was starting to be
like
no no let's let's let's uh let's not eat
that
or let's not release that into the into
into the world that's a different
exercise yeah but you can't do that you
can't go there's
then there's lots of things we want to
change right
i mean you know what maybe that would be
wrong because maybe
the world is experiencing exactly what
it's supposed to be experiencing right
now
it's all part of it it's all part of the
process
well i'm glad we talked about this i was
afraid i was gonna look like an idiot
honestly i was like man i don't wanna
answer this question because i feel like
there's some really good answers and i'm
just gonna give stupid answers
i think he gave good answers i don't it
doesn't matter they're my answers
and i came to grips with that right but
thanks for thanks for trying to reassure
me
i'm not an idiot but what are your
answers hashtag gear biscuits oh
but you've got a wreck i got a wreck
yeah oh boy do i have a wreck
oh man i was trying to come up with a
wreck and man i
was like man i'm gonna look like an
idiot
i'm j i'm frustrated i do feel like my
world's gotten so damn small
yeah that i'm like i've even i just my
level of enjoyment has gone down
i gotta i gotta turn a corner i know i
was a bit of a downer last week
i don't i you know this is
this was a lot of fun having this
conversation
good um my recommendation
the best i discovered a new snack
now the the the snacks that always blow
us away
and that are also healthy are these blue
diamond almonds
every time we have them on the show not
a sponsor though not a sponsor
we're just gushing about these bold
flavored almonds like the salt and
vinegar and then the sriracha
and you can buy a variety pack i don't
know how we got these in our house
but i am recommending the habanero
barbecue almonds oh that's a bold flavor
if you're afraid of spicy hot things you
might not want to try these
so that's why i'm making this
recommendation because they're not
actually hot
they're not actually hot and they're
they're so good
it's just they're better than the
sriracha yeah to me
they're definitely better than sriracha
and they're better than the salt and
vinegar
they have a better flavor but it's nice
to have the variety but i'm
that is my wrecking effect this week is
the habanero
barbecue blue diamond
almonds sometimes all you need is a good
snack all you need and
yeah just a handful of why don't we have
a healthy snack
uh salt and vinegar because we got a a
crate of salt and vinegar and what we
should have gotten was
a crate of the variety pack which they
sell yeah because i
i like the sriracha better than the salt
and vinegar and i guess i'm going to
like habanero
what what is it i dig it and i've gotten
tired of those two that's why i'm
i'm not sure a lot of people like the
wasabi and i'm and i like wasabi on my
sushi but i do not like the wasabi
nuts there you have it hashtag here
biscuits
let us know what your answer is if you
could travel anywhere it doesn't have to
be three it doesn't have to be three
yeah just be one you'll be in a bubble
you'll be naked um would you be you know
what temperature controlled you can just
wear
you can wear shorts and not be ashamed
of it yeah you let everybody see the
rash on your thigh no one will see you
they can't see you because then you
could alter it because then you could
just do like
sign language and alter history they
can't see you it's an invisible bubble
but you can get as close as you want to
anything
you can go back to the moment of your
own conception
that would be horrible yeah that would
that would be
really weird to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best